much like protagonist Zack Fair himself
the story of the self-proclaimed Country
Boy turned Soldier first class is not
when shrouded in mystery if you've
engaged with Final Fantasy VII or any of
its various spin-offs prequels remakes
or animated movies chances are you
understand the weight of his legacy
which is coincidentally only rivaled by
the weight of his sword however if
you're looking for the definitive way to
experience it look no further than
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII reunion
[Music]
a remake of the 2007 PSP exclusive
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII Crisis
Core reunion is a faithful retelling of
Zack Fair's story with dramatic visual
upgrades full voice acting and several
quality of life changes
by the way what is your dream
to become first
is it no
to become a hero considering the game
was already heralded as a fantastic
prequel and one of the best titles on
PSP it comes as little surprise that
this version is triumphant and making
Crisis Core into a modern day must play
for Final Fantasy VII fans Not only does
Crisis Core reunion Port the once fairly
difficult to find game to several new
consoles allowing for a greater audience
to experience the title it transforms
the game from feeling like a smaller
handheld experience into something that
can proudly stand beside Final Fantasy
VII remake as a worthy companion Crisis
Core Final Fantasy VII reunion follows
Zack Fair a skilled young man who
quickly moves up the rank of soldier
shinra's Elite fighting force to stand
beside other legendary heroes like
genesis angiel and the later notorious
sephiroth however once information
regarding the various experiments Shinra
conducted on these Elite Warriors begins
to surface the four colleagues quickly
find themselves at odds with each other
inevitably these tensions set into
motion the events of Final Fantasy 7.
including Sephiroth's turn towards
Madness the burning of Nibelheim and
Cloud's involvement in the whole ordeal
however Crisis Core doesn't solely exist
as a precursor to something bigger as it
succeeds in weaving and engaging
intimate and emotionally impactful
Narrative of its own a lot of this is
due to the game's protagonist whereas
Final Fantasy VII's leading man Cloud
Strife has a tendency to be soft-spoken
and a bit Moody Zach is exuberant and
extraordinarily likable throughout the
game Zach's Mentor Angel Likens the
fighter to a puppy and affectionately
teases him for his hyperactivity and
eagerness
however when compared to the other
Soldier members like the stoic Angel the
dark and poetic Genesis and the
no-nonsense sephiroth Zach is a breath
of fresh air who is widely idolized
within the soldier program particularly
by Cloud for his proficiency Zeal and
encouraging nature outside of Shinra
these qualities also endear him to our
favorite flower girl aerith who shares a
brief but Powerful Love Story with Zach
complete with long-distance phone calls
and tender letters in Crisis Core
reunion the emotional impact of all
these events is Amplified thanks to the
entire game now having full voice acting
eyes infused with Mako energy
a soldier trademark
[Laughter]
while some voices might take getting
used to as they differ from the original
crisis core's performances the new voice
actors do a fantastic job in making the
story more engaging than ever before
this voice acting also profoundly
impacts how we've used sephiroth as the
story progresses Tyler hoechlin's
performance makes him even more
sympathetic as the truth about his birth
is slowly brought to light and his
downward spiral becomes more
heartbreaking on that note I was
delighted to hear several of the series
new voice actors lending their talents
to the characters who appear in Crisis
Core reunion including Tifa aerith song
Reno rude and several others this is all
a part of square enix's push to make
Crisis Core more cohesive with Final
Fantasy VII remake which It ultimately
does with gusto this feat is also
accomplished by how much care the team
put into visually upgrading Crisis Core
every location is Lush intricate and has
been adjusted to more closely resemble
the world we see in Final Fantasy 7
remake which makes the game's trips to
junon Costa Del Sol Nibelheim Shinra
Manor and gangaga areas that we've yet
to venture to in the remix but we will
see in the future a bit surreal in
Crisis Core reunion we're presumably
getting our first look at what lies
ahead for us in Final Fantasy 7 rebirth
which if you're a die-hard fan makes the
game well worth playing in itself as
someone who has spent the last few years
yearning to see what wandering through
Shinra Manor will feel like or how Grand
the streets of junan might feel as cloud
is tasked with parading down them it was
an emotional experience to see even a
less graphically intensive Glimpse at
what's on the horizon crisis core's
gameplay systems remain intact albeit
streamlined and remapped in fantastic
ways those not familiar with the
gameplay will find it to be unusual but
exciting rather than Final Fantasy 7's
turn-based system crisis Corey Union
features fast-paced action style combat
while the game simplistic hacking
slashing and blocking is a fun time by
itself with challenging enemies
requiring fast reflexes and quick
planning Zach can also equip up to six
pieces of material which Grant him
spells and abilities he can use in
battle in the original Crisis Core
cycling through all of these combat
options could be daunting as you were
forced to use R1 and L1 to scroll
through them all then hit X on which one
you wanted to use in Crisis Core reunion
this has been completely overhauled as
you can now hold R1 and assign these
abilities to various buttons to make
combat less frustrating and more
efficient Crisis Core reunion also
improves one of the original game's most
notable features the digital mind wave
also referred to as the DMW it's a
constantly spinning slot machine style
combat enhancer that lurks in the upper
left corner of your screen during combat
the icons featured on the slots are
characters and summons you meet
throughout the game with characters
providing you limit breaks based on
Zack's relationship to them and summons
granting you the ability to well summon
them as your relationships with certain
characters are altered you become more
or less likely to see them make an
appearance in the DMW in theory it's an
incredibly strange feature as this slot
machine is responsible for allowing you
to dish out your hardest hitting moves
as well as level up in execution however
the DMW is extremely fun and satisfying
generally working out fairly well for
players while also introducing an
element of Randomness to battles that
keep them fresh in the original Crisis
Core this feature did earn some
criticism for its modulating phase which
would grind battles to a halt as the
slots took up the entire screen these
phases no longer exist though Crisis
Core reunion will still interrupt
battles to show brief cutscenes when the
slots land on certain characters
considering the time we get with Zack is
so brief I found these cutscenes not
only fascinating to watch but needed as
an extroverted person who is supremely
devoted to the people around him just
take a look at how many text messages
the guy gets having this mechanic where
Zack's relationships play a role on his
mental state 8 and subsequently the way
he battles is a brilliant choice that
tells us a lot about him without adding
hours on a crisis core's story all these
unique qualities created tangible
difference in Final Fantasy VII and
crisis core's gameplay which drives just
how different Zach and Cloud truly are
Crisis Core also features Materia Fusion
which allows you to take leveled up
Materia and combine it with other types
of material to create new and more
powerful spells and abilities while
grinding out Materia in Final Fantasy
VII was arguably already fun the
implementation of the fusion system
makes it even more satisfying rather
than simply raising how powerful your
fira becomes Materia Fusion allows you
to create entirely new spells altogether
such as combining said fire with a salt
twister to create Fireblade an ability
that inflicts magic damage while not
using MP Additionally you can add items
during Fusion that when equipped on Zack
alter his stats I spent a lot of time
managing and fusing my material while
playing Crisis Core reunion and despite
being someone who doesn't necessarily
love crafting I enjoyed every minute of
it however not all of Crisis Core
reunion's grinds have aged quite as well
for starters the game has far too many
random battles at times I found myself
sprinting with Zach pressed up against
the game's walls to avoid being in the
centralized areas that trigger them
additionally Crisis Core reunion has a
lot of side missions considering the
game was originally created to exist on
a handheld console it is understandable
each of these missions lasts for a few
minutes and would be ideal to play
through if you have a few spare minutes
while out and about removed from that
context when playing on a console
however these missions are not as
satisfying and considering how similar
they are even if the background stories
are slightly different they quickly grow
repetitive that being said Crisis Core
reunion is marketed as a direct remake
so it makes sense that it's all there
and I can't fault the studio for
carrying over pre-existing content too
much even so the game would have greatly
benefited from finding ways to make this
content more worthwhile and less
outdated and feel really the only
feature I would argue was woefully
neglected by the studio is The Game's
dialogue which can come across as
awkward and very early 2000's jrpg this
is exacerbated by just how incredible
the dialogue changes and additions were
in Final Fantasy VII remake which
enhanced already fantastic characters as
well as made the overall story deeper
and more comprehensible while Crisis
Core reunion did not set out to expand
or reimagine its predecessor the same
way remake did a few alterations and
less awkward pauses from aerith would
have gone a long way ultimately if you
go into Crisis Core reunion expecting a
one for one remake of Crisis Core quirks
and all you will not be the slightest
bit disappointed it is a greatly
improved version of a great game one
that all Final Fantasy VII fans eager
for more story would benefit from
playing while you shouldn't expect any
new content or story revisions my
sincere apologies to all of you who were
still hoping you can expect a powerful
Ode to the kindest man you'll ever meet
and the Legacy he passed on
activating combat mode out of the way
[Music]